you know i have a theory here people
always ask uh
you know people like alex jones or milo
yiannopoulos or laura loomer like why
did they get taken out why did gavin
mcguinness get taken out
and my theory is this is i'm not i'm not
calling them fringe okay and i and some
of these people are my friends and so
i'm not speaking poorly of them i'm
gonna i'm just using the lefts
uh you know using them as as an example
here
they go okay these are the fringe guys
on the right and the left says that
so if we can take these fringe guys out
that we think are extreme in our matter
once you take out the entire perimeter
of the left's
idea of extreme it now makes the
perimeter of what's far
right much more mainstream right and
that being said is where people like
myself then get called far right or
extreme right when i'm like hey
i i'm actually you should know and this
is a common uh
uh rhetoric it's like actually the far
right
really actually hates me they're some of
the biggest spammers
and they're you know stupid alt accounts
and uh their avatars
they're not even brave enough to have
their own profile picture and yet
they're going to save the whole country
from from immigrants or whatever but
obviously they hate me
but what's weird is is that as we've
seen the perimeter keep getting taken
off of the right
so that now just the the small sliver of
the mainstream is now considered the
furthest right
right we haven't seen that on the left
and what's even weird is we've actually
seen
the glorification the financing of the
perimeter
to where the perimeter on the left keeps
going further and further out
so what used to be far left actually
just three four years ago is actually
pretty moderate
and now you have people talking about
the fact that you know
i mean i mean realistically speaking
they're saying that you know the the
army and then the the military is racist
because any time a white man has you
know command over a black man
that's right that's systemic racism and
you're going holy hell do you not
understand how
the military even works this is
voluntary recruits these are people
these people if you know anything about
the military people they don't care
about your sexual orientation race creed
color
they're all about camaraderie and
brotherhood etc and so like what i've
seen is this weird
intellectual warfare where now the
establishment or the real
mainstream right we're all like
essentially
right-wing terrorists according to the
establishment media and the left has
this free pass
to write articles that at some point i
don't even know if they're serious
well so so this is where it gets funny
alex jones used to talk about
something i could be getting this wrong
problem reaction solution
it was something i should say on the
internet way back in the day the idea
being that
you know look these illuminati types
they're gonna create a problem
and then be and then once the people
react they come in and they're the
solution
i used to i remember seeing that stuff
on the internet and the libertarian web
and the conspiracy stuff
the idea being the government sparks the
issue and then only they can solve it
vote for them
they're literally posting that right now
the left about trump
the the left rachel maddow for instance
i mean think about it
there's there's a video from a group
called uh juice media it's rap news and
i think this one is number six
and it's about julian assange and
cablegate back in 2010
when they made this in their parody they
paired they satire
alex jones saying we've we've got to
stop the
the rise of the kami nazi fascists it's
like one of the jokes in in in the video
and he talks about hillary clinton being
evil
quite literally says hill dog your lies
are blatant
and he says you know the nazi fascists
are taking over that was alex jones
that was that was a character that's how
people viewed him in 2010
now those same people who think that
that
you know the fascists are coming they
they like hillary clinton or or whatever
they're screaming
that donald trump is creating the riots
across the country
so that you must vote for him they're
literally pushing the old school
internet conspiracy line about the
government creating problems
so only they can solve it if the whole
thing is
is it's it's weird
it it you know what strikes me the
weirdest is
the fact that we constantly get accused
of being exactly
what the people are that are accusing us
and and i mean this
very thoroughly speaking you know what
people don't maybe don't notice i i run
a show called slightly offensive you can
find it on youtube
it's just called slightly offensive and
i i focus a lot on getting my own
proprietary content i think that a lot
of people
um don't do that anymore i don't i don't
mind but i like to go out it's something
i enjoy doing it's crazy world that
people media still do what they enjoy
but i go out and i capture a lot of my
own footage at riots at protests
at things and i commentate on them and i
have two separate parts on twitter
i'm myself elijah shaffer i'm try to
stay unbiased i try to just give video
reports for other news outlets et cetera
i license
my footage but on my own show we're
gonna let the
s word hit the fan gloves we're gonna go
we're gonna go for it
but now it's very kosher st it's very
kosher i always say that it's about a 14
plus audience if you're 14 and older you
can watch it
that being said when i look at this
i can be using my own footage that i
captured
meaning i'm not like a conspiracy
theorist i'm not ripping footage i'm not
manipulating it even you can't even say
that i'm a propagandist this is my
footage that i was there that i risked
my life to get and in many ways i have
risked my life to get this footage
i'm pretty proud of that meaning there
are moments where i thought i'm going to
die
and it wasn't so i can get clicks i'm
going but if america doesn't see this if
i don't run
towards this they're not going to see
the truth and
and in my mind i'm not you know it's not
no one's like oh it's not like a griff
like i
if i get this i get a million views
because i have a wife you know i have a
family and my mom just died a couple
months ago i can't let somebody else die
in my family
the family my family is broken over this
and so when i'm in these situations and
these race riots
dealing with my own tragic death in my
own family you know i've been married a
couple years taking care of my wife
and i see something happening and i'm
going i've got to run to that
i am definitely thinking just this needs
to come out to america
and then i put that footage oftentimes
censored to meet
you know youtube or big tech guidelines
i keep my commentary kosher anything
that isn't
sensors bleep it out we bleep it out so
that it's just like normal broadcast
television
and then my video gets age restricted it
gets taken down my account
gets gets throttled they tell me i'm
borderline etc
and i'm going wait a second my opinions
aren't even partisan
my when i'm there and i look at at
the stuff that happened in kenosha the
altercation between the young man
and those other individuals when i'm
there and i filmed it and i witnessed it
and the other angles are my friends and
we scoured over this footage and we
looked at it
and we came to a conclusion that's
actually journalism
that's not just commentating that's not
just editorial
if i have four or five angles and
individuals and we discussed and we
talked
and we come to a logical conclusion off
of what we saw
and where we were why are we conspiracy
theorists
why are we the ones that get discredited
but yet journalists
like the new york times and washington
post the night of those events which i'm
going to be careful the way i worded
because i know these these algorithms
the way they try to pick up these words
to just
throw these streams off when i was there
and i watched that twitter
curates at the top of the feed you know
here's what happened
and it's from articles who had not yet
contacted the journalists who were there
who did not quote us who from what i saw
were not on the ground
in that moment it makes you wonder it
makes you wonder
are we really the extreme people are we
the conspiracy theorists
hold on now we talked about the other
day radicalization
what does that mean right people have
become radical right
brian stelter recently was on c-span and
someone called in saying that cnn was
the enemy of truth they've lied hundreds
of thousands of times
and then he says well you know this year
there's been a lot of radicalization
against the media
okay is it radical to want uh borders
for your country
no of course not it's it's the way it's
always been is it radical to want a
strong military
no literally the way it's always been is
it radical to want to lower unemployment
and make sure that the people of your
country have jobs before
immigrants sounds good to me that's
actually the way it's always been
it was only 10 years ago the democrats
were for all of these things as well in
fact bernie sanders was for this only a
few years ago
they've gone so far off the rails
that they're so far left now they're
looking at regular people screaming
radical
quite literally like brian stelter and
that's mainstream news so there's
there's good news here i i wanna talk to
you about the riots too because that was
that was actually really interesting
what you were saying about what's going
on
because i like bragging on the media so
when when i look
at the far left and how far they've gone
i don't think they make up
the majority of people this this fringe
group
i think it's eight percent i've heard
yeah that's the the hidden tribes report
says eight percent maybe a little bit
eric's house a couple years ago so i'm
wondering if
you've got i'll do it this way you've
got mainstream society
and the left starts pulling further and
further left and it's possible that we
get dragged or
it breaks off if the far left moves so
far left that regular people become
confused by what they're doing they
become fringe weirdos
and all of these big mainstream
companies and and the nba for instance
their ratings are in the gutter 40
down you see this i you know what i have
and unfortunately for them i've never
watched them because
it is a grift i mean these guys are
they've always complained they're always
getting hyper political
making millions of dollars talking about
they've not all of them well but okay
yes not all of them but i've seen that i
i'm kind of
anti-elitist like i don't like it's not
that i'm against sports and i love
i love all american pastimes et cetera
people i'm glad people have past times
i just don't like it when wealthy people
who live very comfy lifestyles lecture
america i've never been comfortable for
sure they're not working class
but the the what i'm seeing with this
idea of getting woke going broke it's
not it's not a universal law there have
been movies that have been walked that
have done really really well
but they're not authoritarian woke for
the most part right the the example i
like to give is
into the spider verse where they have
mile morales afro latino spider-man
and they don't make grace the point of
the story like these woke crappy movies
do that end up bombing
so i think the this this
intersectionalism this weird cult-like
behavior
is isolating it's it's it's making
regular people say i don't want to be a
part of this
when they're forced into it and i think
it's possible a lot of
a lot of weak willed people may just be
like whatever you say and buy into it
but i think america is built upon
generations of
defiant individuals i i think about this
way
our culture is very individualist for a
very simple reason
the people who left the european you
know countries to come here
were i would rather land a boat on an
empty shoreline and just start foraging
for food
then deal with you and we're the
descendants not all of us uh you know
because part of my family didn't come
here until the 19th actually i think all
my family didn't come here until early
1900s
or the late 1890s but america is is
has been culturally built off of those
ideas and they don't just go away
so we are very staunch individualists i
imagine most people are going to say
leave me alone or else
so when you start getting the things
you're talking about where they're like
tell the world you're racist eventually
people are going to say
i'd rather go live in the woods and
build a farm
than deal with you and you're weirdo
they are i know they are people are
leaving
the cities in droves i am from los
angeles if people cannot tell
from my slightly uh mixed voice that
sounds
slightly lispy slightly homosexual and
also valley girl together
that's what's called growing up in los
angeles and hanging around
a lot of liberals but thinking for
yourself where's the surfer dude in
there um the surfer dude was the pot i
smoked for like a decade
i mean that that's that's that's where i
sit there and i get confused sometimes i
was just a lot of pot a lot of pineal in
just a few years
but i you know i will say this you know
being there
you know california people have their
own way of speaking i'm very much a
california person
in a lot of ways and i always found it
really funny because there's this uh
group of individuals who got really mad
at me for
uh uh do you know jesse lee peterson is
yeah of course amazing
how he goes gay i just like the guy so
funny he uh
he really is a funny guy and and and he
uh i was on a show and he's like
he always asks questions in this
dichotomy like like
it's for entertainment purposes like you
know like do you love your wife or do
you hate your wife or something and
you're like
oh that's a weird question you know but
like he goes you know are you like a
conservative or are you a
republican conservative and i was like
it's not even hey what's your political
standing i said you know i'm a
california conservative which to people
live in california knows what that means
it means
i hold conservative values but i also
live around
really interesting individuals and i'm
the minority and i've learned how to
work
operate eat drink and be friends with
people who think vehemently different
than what i think about the world and
i'm okay with that
um it means nothing it's not a
complicated saying it's just like
california conservatives always
say that yeah respect that that's cool
yeah i know but these this group of
people got
got like super super mad that i said
this but i think that there's this whole
part of america
that is being ignored where whether you
would call it like a respectable
democrat or a california conservative
there's this whole civil group like the
main swath of america
that is somehow being dejected from the
conversation like you said about people
being called extreme
i've never been considered an extreme
person i
i never in my life have considered my
politics to be extreme i i run into you
you probably run into extreme people
online too
they're there and they exist and they
have the right to exist i'm against
censorship i think people have the right
to be extreme as long as they're
non-violent i think they have the right
to have radical ideas
i think that it's good communists yes i
do
especially communists but i also think
too that like this idea of the extreme
people kind of taking the narrative
and batting it against each other where
where i know the the far right and it's
like 200 people
like that exist and like six prominent
ones by the way this is like 200 main
accounts that i know of
that are far right and so it's really
weird that when the left even says oh
you're far right i'm like no i know the
far right
that's like i can literally tell you
what it accounts i wouldn't do it but i
could show you what accounts are far
right
there's only a few of them but because
they have scapegoated us
as that i just have to be careful on the
right that we're not forgetting
that there's this whole swath of people
that are feeling very much
alienated and homeless from from what
they knew to be the democratic party
and the that's why i don't want to call
it republican i don't want to call it
conservatism
because a lot of these people aren't
conservative but they're right are now
though
but the right wing but see that's way to
be careful not calling them
conservatives
they're not conservative they're liberal
but the right wing now includes this is
the weirdest thing
and this is where i'm going to get so
much flack
yeah flak for for this from from those
weird anonymous accounts probably
but but i'm okay to say this is that the
right wing has become
so umbrella inclusive that it is now
includes conservatives and liberals even
if people don't like that
because it's it's become the common
sense
party essentially i said i sat down with
glenn beck and we disagreed on pro-life
versus pro-choice at the end we shook
our head we shook hands and
it was great great to have me and we
disagree and i don't
like it it was it was the exasperation
was kind of funny because i was like i
really think the best way to put it is
we have
a different like there's an ethical
barrier between us
but we recognize we should sit down and
just keep talking to like
figure out each other's world views yeah
but why mock why mock the
the moderates and i think that's what
that's what i come down to is is that i
want to acknowledge that there's
extremists on the left and the right
it's just that the right-wing extremists
are still fringe
and that's the key thing is they try to
make it seem like those people that are
right-wing establishment are fringe and
extreme it's like no
there are some right-wing extremists
what i'm upset about is not the fact
that you guys want to call out extreme
right-wing people i'm mad that while
calling out right-wing extreme people
and talking about the negativity of who
they are
you then put on a pedestal left-wing
extremists
like if you're going to fight against
extremism you've got to be consistent
because that's what that's what
frustrates i think that the average
individual and why more people are
defecting towards i wouldn't even call
them republicans
or right wing but they're becoming trump
supporters or america first
they're getting behind america first
mentality you're looking at one yeah
exactly is that you're just going
i literally can tell you this i don't
agree with everything on the right i may
not be as
the most conservative guy that lives
maybe in you know
some some south uh southern state or
whatever but i can tell you that that
whatever this
insane militant communist faction is
that has hijacked what they're calling
the democrat party
and is quickly seemingly becoming the
establishment democrat party
is just detrimental it's toxic for the
future of our country
and i don't want any part in it ala you
you could not possibly have a more
so so i'll put it this way let me let me
start over if you took the democrats
and you looked at where they were in the
last election
and then you take someone like aoc or
any member of the squad
and you actually map their personal
policy positions they've espoused
and their calls for unrest like iona
presley they are
so far left you can't even call it
radicalization it's something extr
it's extremism it's like if if
if aoc really is the new face of the
party which a lot of people have said
maybe she hasn't but she's got you know
8.5 whatever million followers it's
crazy
you go from a joe biden saying you know
barack obama's administration they
called obama
the deporter-in-chief because he
deported so many people now
now you've got biden saying moratorium
on deportations decriminalizing border
crossings i think biden may have said i
could be wrong about that
but uh he's talking about a moratorium
on deportations and i'm like that's a
180 from from
they've they've convinced biden to adopt
radicalized positions
so it's a fact and they and and joe
biden comes out recently and says do i
look like a radical socialist and i'm
like no you look like a bumbling old man
but you've come out in the debates with
these insane fringe positions that
nobody wants
except for a tiny fraction of screaming
people and well that's what's coming
into mainstream politics
but that's but that's what strikes me as
interesting because what i realize is
this and this is where
this is where i think i know why this
has happened okay because
what happens is that people lose touch
with reality
and i know this because when i watch
influencers right and i watch people
i will see and and i i talk to um ezra
levant
um at rebel rebel about this about how
a lot of influencers uh on the right get
pulled towards extremism
because what the this is this is i'm
gonna make a point about the left here
what the extreme fringe right does is
they essentially
try to make you seem like hey we're the
real right we're the real cool people
we're the puritans we know what's really
going on
without us the country is left and
everybody else is a sellout and a fake
and here's the thing we might have some
weird ideas about certain races and
people but just listen to this
everybody else is selling out the
country and if you really want to save
it you got to come
closer and closer to our ideology and
then you share a couple ideas that might
agree with what they agree with because
i mean take any random sample of people
anybody might agree with something you
say
and then they start getting mad that you
that you don't agree with everything
they agree with because
clearly some of their ideas are
extremely toxic and then they start
they demonize you so what happens is
someone could have 200
000 followers on twitter but then they
have 2 000 of these like random accounts
multiple are run by the same person
flood their inbox go on there if you're
a small-minded person who's out of touch
with reality you think oh my gosh
everybody wants me to go towards these
extreme ideas my base it's like right
now
bombing you have 200 000 followers these
are 2 000 people who you can look don't
even follow you
it's not even one percent even if they
did follow if you're following this is
not who you should be listening to
this is mob mentality these are
extremists who are trying to push you
into this cultic idea that what you're
doing is somehow
ruining the country unless you follow
them now i know that you know that
you people who work on the right that
are smart know that or left
that extremists don't aren't the status
quo but if you are easily manipulated
like joe somebody who's bumbling
mentally incapacitated in some ways
these people are dangerous in the fact
not
violently intellectually they will take
advantage of this is
literally what's happened the democrat
the democratic party
uses twitter as their public opinion
barometer
so all of the fringe extremists on
twitter
who will bombard one of these
journalists or these politicians with
crazy opinions they think people must
want this
exactly and regular people aren't on
twitter it's like 22 percent of the
country is active on
no no i think it's less than that i
think uh i forgot the numbers
on that i went on social blade um just
to see if like oh i grew a little bit or
whatever it says website
this is not impressive i'm not boasting
about this but it said i'm like number
40 000 or whatever on twitter
so we and i'm not even very big so if
you just took that swath of like 50
000 people that are like in the hundreds
of thousands and verified to millions
that's 50 000 people
out of a population of what three three
fifty three seventy three twenty eight
or something yeah okay so over 300
million people
you're talking about like 50 000 people
deciding the discourse
of the whole country maybe take out half
of those of people who probably don't
engage politics online yeah
so like 25 000 people
are literally creating the entire
narrative
for what's the whole country and i mean
not that i'm not influential or anything
i'm just pointing out the fact that
like 25 000 people out of 300 million
plus
sort of dictating what the news is what
goes on shows et cetera
that's less than two percent and when
donald trump then invokes
law and order and regular life
regular people just like normalcy
that's that's that's what they're trying
to do with biden that was one of the
arguments that joe biden invokes this
idea of normalcy
it's like remember remember the obama
years when life was regular
vote for biden and it might work and
they say donald trump's the cause of all
of this it's not true
but donald trump says law and order so
you're getting that when you got fined
for not getting medical insurance like
that was normal
yeah yep thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you